[Music]
kanye west's third listening party for
his latest album donda was straight fire
no but really kanye lit himself on fire
i mean it was just fun to just
just do something for my heart on
thursday the 44 year old rapper hosted
his most recent in a string of donda
listening parties at soldier field in
his hometown of chicago
[Music]
and kanye he set himself on fire in a
stunt that thankfully was just that a
stunt
[Applause]
the whole thing happened at the end of
the show while the grammy winner stood
in front of a replica of his childhood
home
[Music]
but the runaway rapper's fiery
performance wasn't the only thing that
got people talking i'm just extremely
happy can you tell by my face
kanye brought out two celebs who are
currently facing controversy marilyn
manson and the baby the rocker who was
dropped by his label earlier this year
after a number of women came forward
accusing him of physically mentally and
sexually abusing them joined kanye on
the field
as for de baby whose homophobic rant at
the rolling loud festival in miami
earlier this month led him to being
dropped from several other festivals he
showed up and took over jay-z's verse on
a donda track that was previously played
at the first listening party in atlanta
and you can tell my baby mamas get the
bear money
i said one thing they ain't like through
me i like kill for me of course all this
comes after kanye straight up levitated
with the help of some wires and dramatic
lighting during his second donda
listening party in atlanta earlier this
month
[Music]
kanye's estranged wife kim kardashian
was there to support her ex and even
shared the show-stopping moment on her
instagram story
but before his gravity-defying moment
kanye held his first listening party on
july 22nd and after delaying the release
of his 10th studio album which is named
after his late mother the rapper was
actually living at atlanta's
mercedes-benz stadium as he continued to
work on his new music
[Music]
well as of today still no album but he
sure knows how to keep us entertained
while we wait
[Music]
[Applause]
you